wow gorgeous
so we are heading our way to Lee Canyon
Lee Canyon I would describe as like the
Big Bear of Vegas where it's like the
closest snow resort and we actually been
here before Target took a little ski
lesson you can watch that Vlog and I was
snowboarding and then on my feed that
shows like all these outdoor Vegas
activities I found out that the ski
lifts are still in operation during the
summer and what's really cool is you can
take them and they'll take you to other
Trails so the ski lifts they kind of
double the purpose where it goes from
hitting the slopes to if you want a
mountain bike or if you want to hike and
do all that and then I also found out
there's like other activities up there
so we're going up there to explore and I
did not realize how beautiful Lee Canyon
is and look look how densely like the
forest is it's not crazy
beautiful it looks like we're on our way
to Yosemite or something yeah especially
right now that like winner has melted
everything away spring has sprung all
the stuff
all the all the new plants the Springs
have sprung up all the plants it's all
green and beautiful and this is why the
Summers kills everything this is only 30
minutes away from Vegas so far and
what's also cool that's cooler than
Vegas so in Vegas it's about like 90
degrees right now and if you look at
where we're at it's 76. so it's gonna
get cooler and cooler the higher we go I
believe the difference is around 20 to
30 degrees at the top amazing so we'll
see how nice it is we got to come here
during the peak summertime some parts
still got snow in the mountains you see
up there I don't think that's no who is
that snow yeah the little pieces of snow
up there still
or what do you think that is that just
rocks
sand
at the top top at the bottom it looks
just like dirt
top top I'm not sure
right up
we're gonna get closer hold on
hold
I can't tell you oh I think it's just I
don't know no I think it's snow
thank you monkey thanks dude this is
white
snow is white yeah and that's impossible
it's supposed to be all water
so this is completely different than the
last time we came last time we came was
covered in snow now it's just covered in
green trees but it's the exact same
Mountain which is super cool
lot of people bringing out the road
bikes
the ski lift and uh
they're gonna the ski lift actually
takes them up to all the trails and I
believe these slopes kind of double as a
mountain bike trail
um I heard of a trail that doesn't even
need a ski lift that's one thing I am
worried about is I don't know what this
little guy would feel comfortable on ski
lift just yet so I'm looking for this
one called bristle Cone Trail
and uh apparently you get like pretty
nice views I don't know how long it is
some of the trails out here are like
five six ten miles long because they're
really big
so I'm just gonna go with the flow and
see
where we end up exploring to but oh it's
right there Bristlecone
Trail
wild dogs
I love seeing them off leash
CUNY
wild dogs
so we found out is uh dogs are actually
allowed on the chair lifts and there's
one that's made just for mountain bikes
and then there's one that's the scenic
one so us pedestrians can go on it and
we could bring the dog so we're gonna do
that for sure but they don't open until
10. so it's 9 30 right now so it's gonna
kill like 30 minutes and then when I go
up there and I bet the views are going
to be insane so I'm really really
excited
what'd you find young man
whoa you okay
what are you guys smelling
found some more stuff follow
him follow him
hey monkey Cheetos right on your back
too I see him
come on Papa linos
what'd you find Mister
a bathroom thingy
yeah
no those are four jumps and stuff when
it's like snow season
it out watch out there's a car coming
car in the corner a black Toyota Tacoma
really sick one
I'll go after this one right behind this
one okay
okay ready goopy coops we're gonna go
after this one
here we go
good job monkey man
good job dude
all right so I'm on the lift
with Cooper for the first time
CUNY guy
look at this
this is awesome I'm so proud of him I
thought I'd be freaking out but he's on
me holding on to him I want to make sure
he feels secure because we are pretty
high off the ground
so
we got to make sure he feels safe
so I didn't know this but uh apparently
you can't hike up there it's just a
Scenic chair ride so as soon as we turn
around
it's all downhill looks kind of scary
look at that oh my goodness
so I just got to be brave with Mr Cooper
because I know he can feel my heartbeat
so I just want to stay relaxed
it does feel pretty damn scary
I think I could hear a tiger crying in
the back because he's probably scared of
heights a little bit so probably gonna
put this camera away
and I'll wait till I get down to the
bottom of the Vlog but this is the
scenery
is
good boy
okay made it down safe
let's see how mama and the young monkey
taika and Mia do
I like his little bucket hat
cutie
no you could do it just jump just jump
off and run forward not yet not yet once
you get to the platform there you go run
run run good job yay we made it thank
you
I feel that I was pretty scary on the
way back down here
tiger you were scared yeah he was like
I'm freaking out right now
freaking out
right there
I like to throw with both my right hand
and my left hand but what I can do is
I'll start with my feet together
keep my hand at a 90 degree Ang or my
elbow at a 90 degree angle step and then
follow it like that for your left hand
it's the same thing just
like right
you go throw all three for your turn
if one lands on the ground picks up the
ones on the board first okay so forward
then the ground if any of them are ways
to grab high and you can't reach them
just let me know we'll come help you get
them down we don't want people jumping
or throwing another ax to try to get an
ax down okay
yeah if it gets stuck you just let me
know and I'll come help you
I'm gonna spray off your board real
quick oh okay mister did you pay
attention
okay okay thank you
get close get close up to the red line
there you go okay right there there do
what you told you
and then remember she said take a step
and throw forward yep
oh my goodness
okay next one yeah
let's see straight like that oh close
pretty close ready just keep it straight
like this
foreign
okay we saw what your son did let's see
if you could do any better
whoa
whoa getting closer
whoa mama got all the way down to four
that's pretty good huh
okay my turn
all right Papa's turn the first one I'm
just I was trying to gauge yeah excuses
right off the bat why you didn't do good
huh this is right off the bat damn
you're a true content creator am I I
don't even know why not do this
correctly
make it wide and you should be fine
and then tiger gets to go again
okay it's okay just go
all right
oh sure sure nice
I like it
nice
what are your excuses
hey what's the rules one person at a
time
I really love how dense this Forest is
so this hike is called the Bristlecone
Trail
but
it's really tight so it feels like
you're really just going through the
wilderness
versus a lot of trails since when people
go through them they're pretty wide so
it feels like more like a park with
trees whereas this really feels like
your nature like logs
that have collapsed due to Natural
reasons
and super tall trees
it's beautiful
and Cooper's doing really good so far
oh mister
Mr Cooper
okay listen
[Music]
of course as soon as I say listen all
the nature sounds stopped but it sounded
like a Disneyland ride like it sounded
fake it was so rich with nature sounds
can you hear that
it's beautiful it's beautiful to hear
those kind of sounds
and the altitude here must be hot
because I'm out of breath
either that I'm tired because
as you guys follow me on Instagram
you'll know that uh preparing for a
bodybuilding show
so I've been a caloric deficit for like
six weeks now
so my energy levels are low
and man just even walking
is really tiring but it's so cute to see
those guys running around I love it
yeah
what'd you guys find
what'd you guys find over there
what'd you guys find over there hmm
I see one
see the other one
and the furnace monkey
good girl Mia
what a good listener
so Mama give me the magic words she's
like okay
when do you want to turn back around
I'll say let's go right now I'm
literally dying because I'm on a deficit
but I don't want to ruin the family fun
and I think we saw enough and it is
getting close to lunchtime
and so I have all the excuses to be a
big weenie
cut and having a caloric deficit yeah
and having Zero Energy I'm like dude I'm
gonna die remember the cut the last hike
we went off yeah and this was the this
is this is even a harder cut than get
lean so I'm getting ready for a show
yeah so I'm sure you're way way way more
dying yeah like just to put into
perspective I think get lean for most of
it I was at 1900 calories
this one so far my average is probably
like 1500.
so yeah and then Jill's a lady and she
has less mass less muscle than me and
her's not even that low so like I wake
up literally starving and hungry every
day and I just try to put off lunch as
soon as I can because if I eat lunch
then my appetite opens up and then I'm
starving I'm a voracious appetite
so
it's kind of what's happening right now
so I need to
I need to eat something to be honest
made it back to the car
man boy is my morale and my energy level
is low
we still got a decent hike kind of short
but it was only like about a mile and
1.29.3 then in about 45 minutes as I was
saying a slow pace
um even if I didn't could do like two
three miles easy no problem or typical
hike I think is about three miles
without uh with him without him we've
done like up to five as a casual one
but it still helps me get a ton of steps
in today which is really important to
stay active and also like a good
disconnect you know like we're so glued
to our phones electronic devices
constantly being stimulated by news
drama click bait all that stuff so it's
always good to just come out here even
for I think we came out here maybe
around nine almost 12 now because we did
all the ax throwing and then the ski
lifts and everything just to disconnect
for three hours and just to be with the
family and the CUNY for puppies you know
and so that feels really good so even
though my mind and my heart is tired
um my soul feels fresh and now I need to
go get some food
all right guys I'm home
literally dead
Zero Energy
that doesn't make any sense
okay I'm literally dead
and and this morning
um before we got the show on the road I
went to Starbucks and I had a little
cheat drink
and so I kind of have to pay for it now
I need to fit a ton of protein
under 500 calories so I'm going to show
you guys what I've been eating on a cut
it doesn't have to look pretty does not
look good it just has to hit the
nutrition so this is meal two and like
any good boy you or good girl you always
want to plug in your food before you put
in your mouth because once it goes in
your mouth you can't undo it you know
but you can calculate how much food
you're going to put in so you see I have
uh just one Patty and 96 for
a 96 lean Patty right there put that in
I got solid tuna I'm gonna use all three
servings in this can so that's 270.
these angel hair konjac noodles have
been
a lifesaver shout out to Nadine we're
putting me on these guys it's only five
calories per so I'm using two of them to
have a lot more volume to feel satiated
I found this Barilla almost zero fat
um
marinara sauce and I also found this
zero calories I don't even know how they
make this alfredo sauce I'll make like a
pink sauce with some tuna and have a
little Patty on the side and this should
be pretty filling for only
500 calories and that puts me back on
track where I get to have something
that's 630 calories later for dinner so
even on an insane diet you still kind of
wiggle room and you can kind of like you
know give or take like this morning I
was like you know what I'm in the mood
for a nice little dessert drink from
Starbucks
I drink it paid for it or I'm paying for
it now
um so now gotta figure out a way to get
back on track but so this right here is
a total this whole little enchilada
right here is 85 grams of protein with
only 7.5 grams of fat and only 24 grams
of carbs
pretty good
hey Google three minute timer
sure three minutes starting now
so one thing with these contact noodles
you almost have to boil them or else
they're like pretty gross because it
does not taste like noodle texture it
has like this weird poppy Bean sprouty
taste and what I've noticed is if you
boil it for three minutes first it
softens it up and then if you close your
eyes you can kind of pretend like it's
close to a noodle so a lot of it is just
about pretending and faking orgasms
which I'm sure you're a professional at
wait no wait never mind I always give
you real orgasms don't I
yeah
anyways see Geo's a good wife and
everyone lets me know when she fakes it
so I put it in here for three minutes
let this boil soften up while
um I'm gonna cook that Patty on the side
and then I'll make that random pink
sauce
so next thing I'm doing I'm just cooking
one burger patty
kind of like a little steak on the side
and no it's not really part of the
recipe or Cuisine I'm going for because
as you can see I'm making like a pasta
but what I realized for my psychological
satiating like just having a pasta with
sauce doesn't really feel fully so a
filling what am I even saying so I need
to have something that like I'm like
chewing like I'm like a carnival like
there's meat because like once I blend
this into the sauce it just becomes part
of the sauce and doesn't really feel
like you know so I'm putting this just
on this side just to have a little
action
which is also kind of cool because
whatever meat juices come off which is
very little because 96.4 I'll be able to
use as a flavoring agent in my pasta as
well
so burger patty is done move that over
here now time to make the sauce just
gonna use this minced Korean garlic this
has been super helpful throw it on there
to get a little bit of that flavor then
well it's really hard doing this
one-handed operation get some of the
Smyrna
right here dump about a cup probably we
need a cup to always overshoot it oh
what in the world
jumped out
now it's not mixing it around
oh the garlic
the garlic really makes it
taste insane to be honest
so we got that on there
now the Alfredo oh I forgot the tuna
it's important to get the flavor into
the tuna
so here we go
probably need a little bit more tomato
sauce
all right so I just said it and I
just threw everything in there because
I'm so tired and I'm hungry so I'm gonna
just start mixing the tuna and the sauce
this actually looks good I don't even
think I need the Alfredo sauce but I am
curious so I did just buy that
so I am going to eat it together
but
so far you know what
effort I don't want to this looks good I
don't want to ruin a good thing
because especially when it's like this
much where if it ends up not being good
then I have to throw the whole thing
away you know so right now I got this
and I got the Patty that looks like
it'll be good all together
look at this this looks not bad at all
that's it that's it guys
garlic marinara tuna
contact noodles
bam and a big mess
okay Moment of Truth
I have no idea how it's gonna turn out
but I got
tuna and tomatoes tuna yeah I dumped the
whole can of tuna in here disgusting
well it's like meat sauce right so yeah
but it's fish surf and turf baby
I was gonna ask you how does it look but
now I know your answer is disgusting
[Music]
where are your veggies at too dude
it's not bad actually tomato sauce
really good
it doesn't really make me appreciate
Olive Garden right now though all the
what those really make me appreciate
Olive Garden right now oh God
and I hate Olive Garden
we can have a little garlic bread
[Music]
now I'm joined by Mama Bear
and Taco Bell Mama made some yummy fried
fish in the toaster came out really
crunchy toaster oven toaster oven
we got some leftover fried rice
I love when we are able to recycle food
as you can see I'm done with that big
old plate
I use two packets of the contract
noodles because I have the insane
appetite I think for the regular person
in one packet is good enough I'm one of
those guys that can go to in and out and
put down four four by fours like it's
nothing so don't compare yourself to the
way I eat
[Music]
but this is the most stuffed and not
satisfied I've ever been in my entire
life I'm stuffed like I literally can't
eat anything else
but I also felt like
I had no satisfaction of eating a yummy
meal
but
that's what I guess bodybuilding's gonna
be like
so
I got another
about a month and two weeks
I know
this is one of those one and done things
I just want to go through it push my
body through it
get myself super lean I figured it's
like one of those where you bite the
bullet right get yourself really lean
lean even more lean than your ideal
that way when you start introducing food
you can kind of dial it back to where it
is ideal and they figure out a way to
maintain
and I'm gonna be 40 next year so I'm
like I might as well just do this now
and then just maintain the level of
leanness I want to be for the rest of my
life rather than all these crazy
fluctuations so I am going to be the
leanest I've ever been and I might even
be there now already but I'll be like
sub 10 probably
hey
security
all right so mama has been cleaning up a
storm because we got family coming over
soon
and what's it does not look like there's
any progress
whatsoever there's a guy that was
sitting on the couch but no there was
this was all packed all right it was
stuffed
[Music]
yeah so that's ignore that yeah but all
of this is going away is this gonna be
done tonight or tomorrow no it's ready
to go I just need to put things in their
place now oh like there's just a bunch
of little knick-knack things but it's
getting done what's up baby
but yeah a lot of old broken toys just
kind of I'll ask them do you want to do
that like look at all these bins are
empty now yes I have a whole open space
there kind of hard to oh that is open
space yeah it's kind of hard to tell the
progress when it doesn't look like it
has progressed
[Music]
another really weird meal I know just
two more patties and
got some Japanese pickles which I love
and some regular pickles
so the Japanese pickle is daikon which
is like a radish
salt crunchy
so good but just kind of happens when
like you're on a really strict diet
bodybuilding prep
and you kind of indulge a little bit you
have to pay for another two meal so the
way that I I've been been able to
psychologically manage it
is if I want to indulge one day then I
just know the rest the next the two
meals are gonna be trash look forward to
the next day and kind of go day by day
by day almost like when you're running a
marathon you go mile by mile by mouth
kind of same concept
I was at the grocery store earlier
and I saw this
Walden Farms makes
a fat-free ranch dressing
zero calories actually I don't know how
this happens but cannot wait to taste
this on the burger I know could be kind
of weird
but when you're
in diet mode dude
anything any flavor is good so I'll try
this out and let you guys know how it is
all right moment of truth just pour some
on the plate of this Ranch I just lick
the bottle
very watery
definitely does not taste like a regular
Ranch
but I think if I mixed it into something
it wouldn't be bad it's just by itself
it's like nothing beats that like either
Chick-fil-A dip or that thick buttermilk
ranch you know
but on a diet can't complain I'm
definitely gonna use some of that on the
burger with some ketchup and that's my
meal oh by the way I also shared one of
the patties with the doggies in that's
what they're waiting for
bikinis
okay mama said taika's room is really
done this time uh
just organization okay
show me show me the toilet
streaks on the carpet I like that I like
what I see but I I got rid of a lot of
this stuff and I just left big toys on
here okay can you buy his actual
Furniture like this like a toy organizer
yeah this is not his okay
um so I just condensed a lot of the
little knick-knack things that he just
doesn't play with or he outgrew or just
broken yeah so this is again ignore this
thing because that's his Apartments but
that's just the he plays with and
that's the he plays with that's
cutie I love all these toys yeah he has
a box of just cars
so I'll do that tomorrow before our
guests get here but yeah even this I was
able to condense
that was like a whole oh yeah a bunch of
this
we're not there yet one day
it's been almost a year that we lived
here and we still have boxes yeah I mean
our backyard's not done we still gotta
organized garage it's been a slow
process little by little but yeah little
by little hopefully by the time it's
ready to sell this forever home will be
organized
that was our day
I'm gonna continue folding laundry
and wrap up everything to get ready for
all the guests we'll see you guys
tomorrow bye